so last night I got a FaceTime call from
none other than miss Andrew Letterman
herself and guess what I got I got a
tour of her reptile room it was a long
tour it was really long I was up late
she was like how wait what are those
tanks what are those tanks I was like I
know it's crazy you got the cribs tour
but the lizard version it was really
confusing it was
exhausting um she went too fast on
certain tanks so here's the thing when I
pictured your reptile room I kind of
pictured like a dedicated wall right and
I kind of thought like maybe there was
going to be like two or three big things
and there would be a bunch in
one no each reptile has its own they
have to have their own specific clits
they have to have Todd likes making the
terrariums too we have one that's called
we named Chucky because it's evil and it
bites chunks out of you so we have like
um like all like w what's Chucky Chucky
what kind is he what kind of um reptile
he's a gecko um I don't remember what
type of gecko there's a little there's a
cute little red Gecko and you got the
Pug no gold crested yeah we got the the
hog is that your favorite the hog noos
snake she didn't get saw the black snake
I'm a gecko girl you're a lizard girl
half of them sleep during the day half
of them sleep at night and then Todd was
getting mad he was like don't wake that
one up like it's trying to sleep right
now the skank he wasn't he was out he
wanted to see he came towards me and
again again I pictured one wall but no
Annie's reptile room is confirmed a
360 immers submersive
experience where you are surrounded on
all walls what are you are you guys
going to do like a live
feed yeah oh a live feed of so if I like
if Esther and I just want to check in
like big brother style I mean here's the
thing Todd sometimes goes on his twitch
I don't know why people aren't on it
more because you will catch me talking
[__] on very famous people I I do not
know he's on air I am like you are
hearing my true feelings about everyone
I'm like this is literally the hottest
twitch and there'll be no one on
it slugs we have the biggest
announcement of Our Lives pinch
yourselves pinch yourselves he ain't
dreaming we are finally here today to
tell you that on September 12th the day
after you oh Annie that's not
relevant you can finally get trash
Tuesday merch and it's so cute we had
cool awesome designs each of these are
available just click the link
below we have look Kila and are modeling
them in extra larges that we're wearing
as dresses I'm wearing a small tank top
and it's my favorite tank top I've ever
owned I love it so much it's so cute I
wore it on stage last night everybody
loved it um we're so excited about our
new merch we're going to be wearing it
24/7 because we can't believe it took us
two years to get here these are so comfy
so cute cut them crop them
and then send us and then go out in the
world and meet other slugs and talk
about skull you know what to do wear us
um not sure if you heard the huge news I
got Co it was really horrible it still
is um but actually it's a lot better and
I'm really thankful I had to reschedule
my shows but thankfully they're on the
books so soon so uh Boston I'll be at
the Wilbur November 4th and in
Washington DC my shs are rescheduled to
November 5th and also that week November
2nd I will be in San Jose and next week
this Thursday October 5th I will be in
San Diego and soon after that I'll be in
Detroit Chicago you guys can get tickets
at Esther on i.com I can't wait to see
you there um and hopefully everyone has
a better immune system than I do
hey sluggy Welcome to our new set we're
so excited so many fun things coming I
am on the road as always I'll be in
Austin Texas at the Vulcan October 6th
and 7th I'm going to be in La Hoya
shooting my comedy special October 13th
and 14th I'll be in San Jose California
at The Improv November 17th and 18th and
Houston Texas December 15th and 16th I
am always adding dates so go to any
letter.com shows for tickets this show
is sponsored by better help make your
brain your friend with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com TR Tuesday today to get
10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com TR Tuesday thank you to our
sponsor nutriful for a limited time
nutriful is offering our listeners $10
off your first month subscription and
free shipping when you go to nutri.com
and enter the promo code trash find out
why over 4,000 Healthcare professionals
recommend nutriful for healthier hair
nutri.com spelled nuu t fool.com promo
code trash that's nutri.com promo Cod
trash you guys can I tell you why I'm
really proud of my people yes it
actually makes my heart swell so you
know Taylor Swift has just you both of
you went to her eras tour she's going
all over the world she's then going to
Asia but she's skipping out on the
Philippines what but you know what the
Filipinos did they made their own Taylor
Swift and she is now touring all of the
malls and the con these shows are full
on hype like I can you pull up a video
that is the most inspiring story I've
ever heard it's and she I don't know if
she's I don't think she's lips syncing
anything but she's actually very very
talented so we should bring back and
like normalize cover bands her name is
Taylor
shees NPR has an article about it do you
think Taylor oh she's gorgeous oh my God
that's so funny Will Taylor Swift kind
of be like the next Elvis where she's
going to be like the most impersonated I
hope she gets fat honestly I'm not
trying to be rude but I didn't mean that
way can we pull up the video of her of
Taylor she performing because it's so
inspiring and I mean everyone is just
like they B they've forced themselves to
believe they they are in the AOS St I
love it I would why she the
Philippines um I'm not sure but she's
going to Japan CL maybe we don't have
like a big
arena there you go oh my God that's so
funny now is
she is she Filipino yeah she
is
yeah wow it's drag it's
drag she oh my God that's so cute that
is so funny and so she's on tour now cuz
you know there also is a Taylor Swift
impersonator on Tik Tok oh there is yeah
she's AI no she literally this woman I
think her name is like Megan or
something and all the fans know about
her and they'll be like oh that's just
Megan like she has her exact haircut she
looks so much like Taylor and she did a
stunt recently where she went to the
Marana mall and was followed by like
fake security guards and people really
believed it and then like a lot of fans
got mad at her but it's like she was
just having some fun I don't know I mean
historically aren't all impersonators
supposed to do that yeah like that's
their job how many followers does she
have this Halloween I really would love
to see some trash Tuesday impersonators
I would love to see someone pull off
this Trio Halloween has anyone been here
for Halloween I don't know maybe crazy
ex girlfriend yeah a lot of people have
been Bobby and knife or Halloween they
usually carry like a bag of poop or like
a fake bag of poop why is that just
Bobby's you know staple
piece when I went through my um my sword
phase there were a lot of people that
were me for Halloween oh leopard print
jacket and a sword and heart glasses
that's that's a good costume look at
this absolute Stone Cold killer Taylor
shees I mean as a mall [__] myself I do
feel like really drawn to the idea of
performing in malls yeah well that's how
Britney Spears got her star like that's
how they did it in the day do they not
do that anymore I don't see that people
aren't really at malls that much they're
not yeah I mean maybe they are I don't
know that is the like such a Grassroots
route to stardom is literally performing
in malls and just like hoping the
teenagers will catch wind and Care AER
was a mall performer really they would
have like you could meet models from
like ym too at the mall oh that's go
meet smart or something did you guys
ever do the thing at limited to where
they had like like you like the
customers could go in and be a model for
a day no my friend did it and invited me
and I got to like walk down the limited
to Runway it was the best day of my life
it was it was really really important it
was two summers
ago I remember um meeting the entire the
cast of all of the WB shows at that time
which was Dawson's Creek and then
seventh heaven that's huge did Json I
met James Vander Jessica Beal I made him
sign my little thing these are the
biggest stars of our life yeah agreed
what did I just watch where Joshua
Jackson was in it it's just I can't oh
was it the affair no the affair I
mean that [__] me up I not seen then
wait what was he he played the husband
in God what was it wait is the affair or
the show with Nicole Kidman and Grant
the affair is that show where they take
each episode it's the man's perspective
and how he saw the relationship and then
the next episode is her perspective oh
okay I will watch that really good I
Joshua Jack I just
can't he's just so good I just feel like
there's been a trend in like oh little
fires everywhere yeah oh that's right I
read the book I haven't seen the the
show he's just so hot Carri Washington
right yeah yeah there's this trend I'm
noticing in like high-end drama limited
series where like there's a murder
mystery and then the twist is like the
kid did it and I'm just like getting a
little exhausted by it
you don't want it to be the kid anymore
yeah it's too easy well how about the
movie Heavenly Creatures that came out
when I was in high school it was Kate
Winslet and the girl from yellow jackets
and they kill one of their parents they
like murder their parents and as a
juvenile delinquent with worst I was the
the sweetest girl at the juvenile
delinquent school I had a friend that
would make me watch us all the time I'm
like we can't keep watching this we're
not going to kill our like she was like
into it into it oh no yes she loved I
was like this is too much I had a random
thought about you which is cuz you know
naked yeah and so were you you you know
how you're a twin I was thinking like
it's so funny to picture like so your
twin brother Max like his his sperm
meets the egg and it becomes him and
he's like ah like I got it and then
you're like no no no like then you come
in and he's so much smaller than me
really yes like well not now but when we
were born I had obviously gotten all the
nutrients like I just
completely everything and when he came
out I came out feet first after him so
the theory is I literally kicked him out
of the was he feet first no he was I
kicked him he came out the right way mhm
so you did technically then get like a
little bit of time we were scissoring we
were scissoring when we came
out okay I do have sorry no go ahead
scissoring is not what we think it is no
I think it's a lot better than we think
it is what I listen every time I've
tried to ask any of my lesbian friend
friends what lesbian sex is they won't
tell me and they're like I can show you
and I'm like I don't that's not going to
happen I want to just be told now I
recently saw um a a porn with girl
scissoring and I thought it was really
hot and I thought to myself wow I've
underestimated scissoring my whole life
because I'm like that is so pointless
but now I'm like wait have you done it
yet I've never scissored oh just curious
cuz you're like out there down actually
that's not true I Annie and I did a soft
scissoring we did a soft in palom
Springs yeah in front of my mom oh yeah
okay her mom was our artistic director
photographer she's like bump Thum bump
Thum bump bump um I was thinking I want
to to say something back at the mall
experiences I went and saw do you guys
remember the show ghost riter that was
on no it was PBS did anyone see that I
don't know why I'm saw yes it was I was
so obsessed with it did you like it it
was like the best show ever it was about
these kids would like walk around with a
pen around their neck and they'd have a
notebook and this ghost would like help
them solve crimes but it would be like
crimes of like sewage getting leaked in
the neighborhood and there were like
Brooklyn kids and Alex was hot as hell
and I met him I went to the mall we met
all the ghost rer kids but me and my
brother would like wear pens around our
neck like we were like Ghostbuster nerds
I mean not Ghostbuster Ghost Rider nerds
I love that version of you what that I
was like into a show oh my God obsessed
with it it's so wholesome but it's sad
to be journaling like hoping a ghost I
mean weren't we all in love with ghosts
Casper oh my God we got to get Deon sa
on Devon we still care about you who's
the other ghost oh ghost dad ghost D
well weren't in love with him but it I
liked it at the time you remember ghost
Dad no Patrick sey another hot
ghost I my ghost experience is more just
like knowing that my grandparents died
in the house that I grew up in so I was
like okay the ghosts are here and they
are my grandparents and they like me so
I like ghosts and I are like really cool
you didn't like feel like you kind of
looked like Casper a little he didn't
feel like a little K you didn't have a
crush on Casper throw a bald wig on this
this is literally
Casper no but I remember the Pizza Hut
Casper toys were like the best part of
my child you didn't watch Casper the
movie I saw the movie but I I was not
sexually attracted to Casper no if
that's what you're asking well Deon s
was the friend was a he didn't play
actual Casper right he was like the boy
in he was a boy yeah no Casper was not
played by an actor it was sa oh okay
yeah wait did he become the Casper at
the end yeah what it's kind of a sad
story what happens like
he he obviously died
yeah but then there's a moment at the
end will you look up Devon Sawa and
Casper you know how we were all sad at
the end of my girl they should have done
like a movie right after where he was a
ghost that we could all like wait what
happened in my girl too I don't know
doesn't he die though at the end of yeah
he does die look at that hair he had oh
my oh my God you guys are free oh my God
Deon saw was in the Philip wait is in
the Philippines that was in 2009 19 I
mean
oops I'm sorry there's no place for
blonde men in my heart I mean my God
that hair so good I'm still I was
thinking last night one of the managers
at the comedy store has like he's
growing his hair out and I was like I
like this hair because I realized why I
like the little flip like Todd's grown
his hair a little bit long like I like a
little flip under the ear and it is
because of Jordan Catalano it will be
Jordan Catalano till I die Jared Leto in
my so-called life can we get a framed
photo of Jordan calano behind an maybe
when he's leaning against oh God damn I
mean he looks like meor no the one okay
it has to be a picture of Jordan calano
leaning the lean into the locker my God
I'm literally
kegling like that that might be it he's
so
hot it was so crazy it was so wild you
guys are oh my God that episode no is
that Laura Prepon no it's um CL D did
you I didn't make you watch it no my
sister watched it like fought for the TV
so whenever this show was on you didn't
want to see it I watched Nickelodeon bro
I was not I was rug ratting it out when
my sister was I was rub ratting it out I
was like oh my God I couldn't let my
parents I was like I can't watch this
with you you can't be here dude that is
oh my God look at him he dresses like
Kila wait can I tell
you so I have the most traumatic
memories growing up of like you have to
watch this it's one season you have to
watch it please okay
just please I'll watch it I'll watch it
you never [__] watched it you're not
my friends by the way Guys these are not
my friends I'll watch it he looks like
me now I have to watch it I think he
looks like me
but wait okay can I tell he look like
neither of you trash humans traumatic
compared traumatic childhood memory is
like walking through the room when your
parents are watching Sex in the City and
hearing those very highly sexual
conversations like just sharing the room
with your parents is so horrible
we watched it my whole family would get
together and watch it my ex-boyfriend
Andrew would come over we'd all watch it
together we'd Watch Sex in the City yeah
so even worse than that my aunties my
horny aunties they would babysit us and
they would watch porn and just tell us
to like turn the other way what as a
group they would just group watch and
then the kids would be like I think
they're you know and that was it but
they couldn't leave us like unattended
so oh my God guys it's backwards but I
don't care it's crazy world it's a
really crazy and then Brian Binger who
works at The Comedy Store
his brother married one of the like Side
characters on this and I I mean getting
to meet her at his wedding
was there are no
words I this is like how I feel about
Back to the
Future
like if I was in the same room as a prop
from the movie I would melt the
hoverboard any prop it's different
because this was a sexual Awakening I
get it I get it I get it well you're not
how do you know that me and Doc Brown
weren't vibing maybe his mom Leah
Thompson what's her
name um how is it how important is it to
you that your partner is funny it's
everything is it really everything it's
the number one is it enough just to
share the same sensibilities or think
the same thing is funny or do they have
to be funny I need to be laughing laugh
in the entire day or I'm not I think
because a good life like I know we did
and I feel like you did too like growing
up and like a funny household where
laughter is such a
priority you I cannot feel a familial
connection with someone if there isn't
that fun laughter and in fact like I
have dated guys for a brief time that
either weren't funny or like I didn't
find them funny and I could never put my
finger on it at the time cuz I was like
too young and stupid but I was like I
remember remember once I was talking to
this other comedian who's like older and
I was like he's like so like how's it
going with that guy and I was like it's
good but like he just says things and
they're like he's trying to be silly and
they're just so stupid and the guy was
like it sounds like he's trying to be
funny and I was like oh I never thought
of it's horrific that's the worst it's
like just no you're not funny I dated a
guy I hooked up with them like four time
like it was not a long thing at all and
I this was when I was a little homeless
so it was like things were getting a
little like what is was a little
homeless it was you know I was staying
on some couches and every once in a
while I couldn't stay on a couch and
then I was like oh no I'm going to have
to bang for shelter and uh so there were
like times I was hanging out like it
wasn't I was I it wasn't because I
always wanted to be hanging out with
this guy that I was hanging out with him
um and he came to one of my shows I did
a show at the Virgil and he was 68 which
Virgil The Virgil in right here on Mon
yeah yeah I love place that's where
that's where I go to [__] [__] up really
there's been comedy shows there they
used to have ComEd two rooms right it's
really cute what a beautiful it's such a
fun place to go danc that bar is like
really nice you're such a like cool
normal person can you imagine dancing at
the virginal makes me a cool normal not
doing show and not getting a drink
ticket like it's so funny that that's a
place where you and I did comedy shows
for 10 years and Kila like was there
partying having fun I love the Virgil
you're So Co the shows were always fun
there they were always good they like a
little upstairs area we would hang out
parking I'm not a fan of parking was a
little rough yeah parking was a little
rough but um all these drunk pictures
were just ubering in so they don't know
what they're talking about here but I um
this guy came and he's so tall like you
see him you know you notice him he's not
like these big like Garfield he was so
annoying
and he tried to be funny I remember Kyle
Canan was that there was at some point
we were all like in a group and he was
just humiliating me trying to tell jokes
like humiliating me and you couldn't
ignore him cuz he was so big like you
couldn't just pretend you didn't hear it
it was I just was like I hate you I hate
you I mean I would rather a guy know
he's not funny and not chime in and just
stay quiet and just nod and observe and
just fall back into the darkness I have
so much respect for that yeah like I'm
okay with that um but if it if they're
trying to be clever around other really
fast people that's an Nick look my
family is divided by people who are
naturally funny and people who are
trying very hard to be funny who's what
my dad is the king yeah he's the king of
it all my dad me my twin brother but he
doesn't always use it he waits it's fun
my Max will like wait in the just in the
on the sidelines of every family
vacation and then he'll just snipe in
with the funniest line of that's the
best role and you're not expecting it
cuz he's just been so quiet so then uh
there's that and then there's my mom and
Timmy my mom is now becoming hilar my
mom has like I don't know if it's my
relationship to her has changed or she's
just letting loose now she's finding
herself my mom is getting so I'm finding
the same thing like my dad has always
been the funny funny funny one but
lately my mom will come in with the kill
That's So Random and like it's just you
would never expect that out of anyone's
mouth um I have an important question
for you though that's coming up which is
like you literally for 10 years dated
arguably like one of the funniest people
in the world what is it like now hard
and they and people it's hard to
probably find a man that doesn't know
what your last relationship was so they
probably have a little bit of a chip on
their shoulder about the funny part yeah
and it's what I'm finding is that like I
get into I date boys and there's always
a point where you're like oh is it am I
going to take the next step like what is
missing and it's always the funny bit I
will tell you Kila my parents um who are
by the way their anniversary is coming
up 50y year anniversary when's our
anniversary because my parents is it's
well it might it might out our thing
but oh
mine's c yeah oh happy but only 36 years
50 years together and are you guys going
to do something big well it's funny my
parents want to have for the whole year
they want to just have they want to have
50 events about like see 50 friends go
out to that is movies things like that
wait want put or golden what anniversary
is you think we would know that I know
who knows we should know this our
parents are trash we love them
but wait but what were you going to say
no but but they laugh like it's that's a
it's like they just laugh all day that's
the thing well that's what sustained
Bobby and I for as long as you know
forever like even when we travel like it
sucks because I date people and then I
hang out with Bobby and then we're just
constantly just being silly and laughing
and you're like [__] like this is the
missing ingredient maybe in this thing
um and I miss it I miss just being so
not PG not PC just saying whatever the
[__] like being around a wild person
like that is really um enriching for me
and also you didn't really like hurt
Bobby's feeling like right like you
could go hard on Bobby and he would be
funny oh my God the funniest that's I
think that's when I'm most free because
I'm pretty reserved with other people
with with Bobby I would go so hard and
he would like like it and we would be
cry he be laughing so mean to each other
yeah so mean yeah that's what's so cool
cuz I've dated comics and like funny
guys before but their egos were like not
right like Todd's funny but you cannot
hurt Todd like you cannot hurt wait I
was oh my God I forgot to tell you this
I like have been bedridden recently and
like I was missing you and I was
watching some Annie wood that was an
episode of you and Todd and I was
literally like oh my God Todd is my
comedic inspiration because you say the
funniest like craziest [__] to him and
it does not it doesn't he doesn't laugh
he doesn't react he doesn't care it's so
[__] funny and I was like oh oh like
that's cuz you know a lot of times
people say like when you make fun of me
and like they like the way like and I
never understood it until I saw yeah
yeah yeah or the best is when people are
like you're too mean to I'm like guys if
you understood the joy she gets out of
me getting one on her but the way you
are to Todd and it reminds me too when
you guys first started dating and my
favorite quote of yours you like he
would do the slightest thing wrong and
you'd be like you're single you're
single Tod you're out we did this one ad
on Annie what I can't remember what it
was for we were like crying L it was
like the most fun I've ever we were like
laughing I was making fun of him for
being weak I was like that he couldn't
put a a poster on the wall by himself
and he just he just thinks it's funny
it's it's the best but um I oh what I
wanted to tell you so my my older
brother
is uh arguably the least funny and the
most try hard of all in my family he
really wants the attention of being
funny he really and so when he does
bring people to my Philadelphia shows I
know that it's going to be a thing and
if I don't surrender to
it um I will be very upset so I have
learned to completely love my brother
and let him be himself and I now bring
him on stage to do standup on my show so
he doesn't Heckle me that's he brings he
always goes inevitably he will he used
to Heckle you my whole family I've had
to yes yes that's really not cool and
honestly before I was even good at
headlining like when it was like very a
struggle for me there's still a man who
comments on everything I do that went to
one show where my mom heckled me and I
bombed the entire show because I didn't
know what to do he I mean it's like
every every time I go to Philly there's
like one guy that comes on don't go to
she's Terri I'm like yes it was a I was
going through a rough patch at that
moment but it was
um yeah I just let him come up and he
just and I just cringed behind him oh my
God fun and it's all it's on film I can
show it to you guys at some point you
should but it was it was pretty crazy he
always takes his friends out for he's
going we're going on a pub crawl I'm
like oh good that's what I love a bunch
of people that don't go to comedy shows
coming to a comedy show wasted they have
no clue they're just screaming out like
heckling so what's your verdict for me
no on um what if he hits all the marks
it's not that he's not funny or that
he's cringe he just isn't you know maybe
we don't share the
same you know level of I really believe
that like with more time and more
familiarity with the right person you
will get to That Fun silly crazy place
like sometimes it does take time like
you you you were with Bobby for 10 years
like relationships get closer and better
and like you get so much more
comfortable in yourself you become a
family and so like I think that you'll
know when it's the right person even if
you're not there yet I think you'll you
guys will grow together to get there
like I have no doubt about that for some
reason but don't you find that people
who aren't funny are annoyed when you're
funny like have you ever dated someone I
have had guys like are you always on I'm
like yes I'm always on what being funny
and Hil all the time yes my brain is
always coming up with jokes constantly
yes wait but you look
skeptical yeah I just don't know what
the you know I
I'm surrounded by you guys by Bobby my
family who's obviously very chaotic and
funny so maybe I can get my fill of
funny elsewhere outside of my partner I
don't know it's hard because I remember
when I when I realized I was into Todd
it was cuz I was like cry laughing at
something you said I was like I could
not stop laughing it's a high that
cannot just it there has you have to
have it and it's so bonding when you
laugh at the same thing together or your
inside jokes well what was it was it
Freaks and Geeks where they he was like
I we watched the jerk and she didn't
laugh at any of the jokes I didn't see
it but that's you never saw Freaks and
Geeks no you I'm going to I'm flushing
her head down a toilet you think I bul
I'm going to bully her even more this is
crazy what's wrong with you I now that
you're sick I'm giv everything I'm going
to make you SpongeBob
Rugrats Are You Afraid of the Dark Kabam
have you seen have you seen have you
seen are you does it hold up have we
seen it recently no but I'm so curious
would love to see it I'm so curious cuz
I used to my mom had to sit in the
living room with me while I watched it
cuz I was scared but I wasn't like too
scared but I needed her there do you
watch horror now you just watch real
real murder I I don't really watch real
murder or horror no I like Thriller like
mystery movies missing
girl missing girl throw a missing girl
at me I'm in oh yeah I love a missing
woman but Todd's now in he you know it's
all in phases Todd's now into real
murder so it's like when I try to put in
like a a fake murder he's like he can't
get on the vibration but I can't do real
murder right now yeah I I'm taking a
break the I can do crime but no murders
like I just listened to this podcast
called the retrievals I just listened to
that too I just told her about it oh my
God it's basically a group of women who
go to a Yale fertil Fertility clinic um
to get their eggs harvested and all of
them like uh complain that the procedure
was like Beyond p pain the extraction
was painful they they were not even like
fully sedated they felt the pain one
woman is like hey just so you guys know
like as they're about to she's like I
feel like I could drive myself home
right now like I don't think I'm
supposed to be this aware and they just
do it anyway and like um and you've had
this done before but it's like they
scrap eggs out of your ovaries yeah
natural I'm sure there's some level of
pain like afterwards when you're healing
but it shouldn't feel like you're being
scooped out um while it's happening
right but I was under under you were
under the very least like Twilight
sitation I think now they use like
propal um but should we like
um tell her are you going to listen to
it you told me you told I told her yeah
oh okay so basically this nurse was
replacing um the fentanyl with saline
and she was taking the fenel for
herself and for a long time between like
for and and I think that like maybe over
like a hundred women basically went
sober and got their eggs extracted stone
cold sober and the part that makes it so
horrible there's it's actually like
there's kind of two Avenues right
there's like the women who they did this
procedure and they actually did get
their um it worked right like they still
got their embryos they they had their
baby they have their family and so a lot
of people are like well what's the
problem like you got but they're like I
felt so violated like they still are
living with this these like emotional
wounds from it and then there's the
other side of it which is the women who
the they found that procedure to be so
painful that they completely gave up on
fertility treatment because they didn't
want to ever do anything like that again
yeah and because women's pain is just
generally all the times minimized right
like I remember being 19 and getting
like my cervix Frozen and me
specifically telling the gynecologist
like I'm I feel like I'm going to pass
out and previous to this they were like
you're not going to feel anything and
they [__] lied I wasn't put in any
sedation I stood up I went pale and I
passed out and they brought me back and
they were like okay now go home I was 19
but it's this is like all of this is say
like this just a chronic problem like
our pain is never listened to it's never
respected it's never relieved why are
you laughing [__] like it's such a are
you laughing cuz you're the one that
complains about pay the most out of any
person I've ever met in my life and I
know that you and I know that you like
feel completely like nobody listens to
your car they don't listen they don't
care I will tell you I don't
care Annie when you got your eggs
extracted I know that you had like a lot
I went to the hos I I was trying to
squeeze a [__] out so bad that I had to
go to the hospital I really I popped I
popped a um assist right you did yeah
what did they do for you nothing they
gave me more things that made me more
constipated I was in Hell more OPI then
I had to get a I I had a doctor actually
a professional doctor tell me that I
could get a colonic doctors always like
don't get colonics he was like you can
get a colonic that's right yes yeah
because you felt super swollen right I
it was the craziest thing when they
stuck the thing up my ass they it went
into a hard
turd oh it was
like but at in the
retrievals basically it's um at the very
end of it they talk about it's not just
this one nurse named Donna who was you
know Donna no offense to the Donna's out
there but that is the name of the nurse
that would still I know that's exactly
what I thought I'm so sorry Donas you
just are that sorry and I also love the
band The Donas but you also seem like I
could have done fent all with you but
Donna definitely was a fentel addict but
she blamed like her divorce and a whole
other things that's the thing is her
then you okay so then you hear about the
nurses who her who did this and I did
find a lot of Sympathy For Her Like
She's clearly going through this
horrible divorce this horrible scary
ex-husband like who's bad to the kids
like it sucks like you feel for her and
then even like the judge who sentences
her gives her the lightest sent
sentencing like four weeks but she could
go home in the weekends oh yeah four
weekends only the four weekends she has
to go to jail so the women they should
have given her nine
months it's such a [__] [__] up story
cuz you are
like I found myself and again I'm not
one of the victims so it's like you're
not it's the first time I've ever heard
you say that I know it was hard it was
actually really hard I I you're like
watching it kind of made me feel like it
happened to me I'm stumbling um but like
you feel bad for her like what good is
it to like punish her and then her kids
are going to have to go with her they're
like terrible dad but then it's also
these women suffered so tremendously
like she should there should some
justice you're like I don't know what
well there's something when something
goes wrong in a medical procedure and it
was on purpose it's like that's where
you're really trusting people and but
it's not even just and there's so many
licenses and there's so many yeah
because I mean even when I was in
nursing school you'd have to go through
the pixus right the pixus is where you
it's it's it's a prison for all of the
hardcore drugs or any drugs really and
so you have to punch in your num so they
know who takes what at what time
everything I know is from Nurse Jackie
yeah that you're talking about so I mean
this huge institution like Yale they
they they there there was like that
machine was too expensive for them they
were trying to cut cost it's [__]
Yale I told Dave I was like Dave your
rival cuz he went to Har I was like [__]
them he didn't really get funny you
landed a Harvard guy I know there was a
doctor who was getting her eggs um um
harvested as well and she was um she was
a surgeon right so when they were giving
her the fenel that wasn't fenel she was
like guys this is saline I know it's
saline I she like no she was an
anesthesiologist she was like I know
this is saline and they were like no
that's your drug she's like nope give me
another bag and then they gave it to her
and she was like that is still saline oh
my God I literally thought of you could
you tell would you be able to know that
I wouldn't I wouldn't she would cuz she
does that every day I pictured Kila in
that role when I was listening are you
like are you like I want Salan
I am so SP just give you like fake IVs
just to make you happy that would what
if we set you up in like a hospital we
just had a fake like a set of a hospital
room I if I ever had like my you know my
mansion with like my uh Barber strand
mall in the basement there'd be a
hospital room yeah I don't even have it
in me to tell my eyebrow person I didn't
go to Aruna one time Aruna is the best
and I went Rog I miss Aruna and I should
I went rogue and I went to someone else
and she say her name though she's always
like how is she I know that's like how
my mom says
it um but I went rogue and I went with
someone else and it was huge mistake and
she was like how do you like him I'm
like I love them I can't tell my massage
person when I feel like I'm on the verge
of that I can know I cannot I can know I
can't tell how's the food wonderful
great you know how your nails love them
listen after gave me after es gave me
those pastries I learned how to speak
up wait you still have to make those I
know I need to redo I need to somehow
I'm giving you actual homework and I'm
going to be mad if you don't do it you
guys know this story Esther might have
switched up the sugar with a salt it
wasn't really that bad I made Annie some
really special fluffy
glutenfree cookies during the pandemic
flaky and
she I do remember watching you from
across the yard you're
like the chances of me liking what you
cooked me were so low
solo you were it was like it just felt
like Esther's playing
house we all have to play pretend that
we like what her easy way no it was good
it just it was just um are there any
gender Norms that you grew up with that
are still so ingrained in you that you
want to shake off but you haven't been
able to shake off I wish I could get rid
of body hair it's just it would be too
hard yes I just have hairy legs and be
fine with with it I'm disgusted by it
when I see it I feel horrible I know
people are just exercising their right
to not partake when I was in Montreal I
did a this show called surrounded that
was it was for Facebook it was like a
meta thing but you you just do crowd
work in a circle of people and I came
out in this girl at hairy legs and my
entire I did just 15 minutes making you
lost your mind I went nuts she was cool
about it but it was like it yeah it's
like that would be so cool if I could
just
unlearn that's a really good answer then
amount of time and money yeah just so
much hair stuff always I think I like
wish I didn't have to be so obsessed
with like food intake cuz when I look
back at those Journal diary whatever
entries from like ages 9 through 12 you
know just like the best they're supposed
to be like your fun best years I'm
literally seeing like weights being
written down like what I ate that day
you should have been watching Ghost G
Rider you would have been like dear
Ghost Rider are there any toxic uh dumps
in my
neighborhood dot dot dot no answer ghost
are you here Ghost Rider like and I've
done so much work on that and I am in
such a much much better place but I do
think there's always that little voice
there of like you your body what your
food you're eating like I think that
that's ingrained in My DNA it must be so
weird too to be like such a short person
and worrying about cuz like whatever
weight you thought you were heavy at was
like a weight that I would never
possibly be the numbers don't make sense
I would never have been like I could
never it's kind of wild that you
probably are the size of when I was 10
Weight Wise you mean and height no I was
taller than wait how tall are you cuz I
remember being 12 and being 5'4 and
115 I'm 5T and 3/4 of an inch I get to
say knew there was a lie in there I knew
get to say it like I think I was you
were my size when I was 8 years old shut
up I'm not even kidding I think you're
like my like second grade third grade I
was very tall I was the tallest kid in
the class except there was one girl
ebony that was taller than me and she
got her period before me how tall are
you guys I'm 5'8 you right now 5'6 but
you know you're not even neither of you
are even that tall yeah it's it's hard
being a tall girl by the way my sister
is 6 feet tall and she's always felt
very awkward and um insecure about her
height I was this height in like fifth
grade like I grew I Middle School I was
this tall that makes so much sense I
don't know why and Max was not Max is
now
5'8 so he's taller than me but it took
him oh
really wow or 5'9 maybe my brothers are
like no my brothers are like normalized
guys I wish I could get rid of this
image that I need need to
be
I cook right and sometimes I don't want
to [__] cook but in a relationship
when I meet someone new it's ingrained
in me that like I am less of a woman if
I don't cook that's Asian [__] it is
Asian of that in a way I wish I don't
have that at all I have not that to
offer I've never had that stress like
especially like when you start dating
someone new and it's like now you got to
bust up you know bust out all the
classic again and I have to show that I
can in my head I was just going to say
sorry to cut we're coule just like
having a conversation without you but
will you give us like a homework
assignment of like an easy good recipe
that we can make will you cook and bring
me food you're crazy you need a meal
prep for you and no she tells me I make
it for you oh oh okay I like
that okay I like that but don't stick it
on me if it's not good this is fun if
it's not good that's her error there
going to be there payback I did make
your chicken thighs several times you
chopped everything a little too
small oh yeah it looked a little bit
neat like yeah you I'll be honest the
directions you gave me were really
limited that's right and I was having to
really invent things and then I showed
it on Tik Tok and a lot of people had a
lot to say about what I did wrong like
they're like where's the seasoning also
do you what's it called yeah you can't
be white and [__] up the seasoning
they're waiting for you they're waiting
for
you they're
waiting this girl's not going to season
anything especially and you're Jewish
it's like definitely not dude I have a
friend who is straight up like does not
salt any of her food I did that for
years CU I didn't know I literally just
didn't know about salt I was like why do
why does restaurant food taste so much
better than mine oh my God it's all the
salt you and Jenna I I do kind of thing
CU my dad had heart he had open heart
surgery when I was in my 20s and so I
did get a thing that salt was bad so I
do I do tend to just like take the hit I
do tend to take the hit of not having
the food taste as good sometimes well I
rather than Salt I'll never do it again
I now I'm a Sal I know how much better
it tastes my dad has like fake salt he
it's almost like salt is the only thing
that matters it doesn't even you could
put on dog [__] and if it's salty if I
put salt on would you would you Slither
up
wait that of slugs
MH oh my God Esther witnessed the snail
eggs she's like literally on FaceTime
with me she's like Todd there's a
million eggs it's so disgusting in his
fish tank he has these snails yeah and
they lay these clumps of eggs that make
me [__] sick I love those I love egg
clumps but the problem with the egg
Clump is that I know how many snails are
going if he doesn't get rid of that
right now we're going to have like our
house will be filled with but that
sounds fun the so you know what you
should do um we Bobby and I did this a
couple years ago we find um stray
puddles like after a rain and we find
straight puddles of tadpoles that we
know are probably going to die in a
couple days when the sun when the water
goes away so we rescue them and we bring
them we watch them oh thank you we um we
watch them grow into little frogs and we
release them back shut up that is so we
did a whole Vlog about them you I'm
going to watch it
this show is sponsored by Better Health
and Esther do you ever feel like your
brain is getting in the way every day
every moment of every day yes I do like
you know what you should do what's good
for you but you can't you just can't do
it yeah it's actually so hard to do what
you know you should do guys if you can
relate to this therapy helps you figure
out what's holding you back so you can
work through yourself instead of against
yourself if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient vent flexible and suited to
your schedule I cannot say this enough
but if in my 20s when I needed therapy
the absolute most there was an option
that I could just use something like
better help where I didn't have to drive
I didn't have to do my own research like
it would have saved me so many tears and
like bad relationships and problems like
we might not have stopped talking for
three years we might this podcast I
would be so healthy this podcast would
not have this my
guess make your brain your friend with
better help visit betterhelp.com Tuesday
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com sltr Tuesday there is a reason
that when you watch this show almost
every single week we talk about neutral
because literally all three of us use it
all three of us have seen results from
it so we are so passionate about how
it's actually not a quick fix scam like
most hair supplements out there like
we've all dealt with hair loss hair
thinning and neutral has been the OWN
option for making my hair healthier
thicker and better and just grow more
and it does take time but that's like
how you know something is worthwhile and
really working and all my baby hairs
have now matured into their pre-teen
years oh they're a little unruly it's a
little unruly but they're little wild
actually nutriful is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
visible thickness and strength from
postpartum to menopause to plant-based
lifestyles and no matter your life stage
neutral has four unique why when you
said life stage did you kind of like go
like this to me you did that to me no
you kind of did like a life stage oh
life stage it's so weird that you I
can't wait for you I can't wait for you
to be 40 I just every day I go can we
speed up time wait nutriful is also now
available in a vegan formula which is
awesome and in a clinical study 86% of
women reported improved hair growth
after taking nutriful women's hair
growth supplement for six months I've
been taking it for years look guys
I I've been thinking about my future a
lot okay and I'm so glad I have nutriful
because I could see myself being an
early wigger an early full wigly say
that you cannot say that you say when
it's a wig person no I can see it I can
see myself being a young person with a
wig with a wig yeah we'll finish that
sentence for
you take the first step visibly thicker
healthier hair for a limited time
nutriful is offering our listeners $10
off your first month subscription and
free shipping when you go to nutri.com
and enter promo code trash find out why
over 4,000 Healthcare professionals
recommend nutriful for healthier hair
nutri.com spelled n u t r a o l.com
promo code trash that's nutri.com promo
code
trash I love frogs when I was little we
used to like whenever by by myself I
would do this like I was so excited
after a rain because I would go out dig
in the mud find the worms like put them
in a little container like a little like
worm what's like where you keep fish
like aquarium terrarium whatever I loved
worms and me and my friends would dig up
for Slugs too she had them by her house
and that was like the most thrilling
like I don't know I felt like I was like
starting my own family like I know some
kids like play with babies and they want
to be play Mommy that way but for me it
was like worms and slugs and snails
and if I ever had seen a frog I would
have lost my mind well this spring when
the rains come we'll look for the
puddles why does sound so cute would
otherwise dry up know it was cute you
just really turn Native American
sometimes it's like crazy she just
morphs like so fast she's trying to get
us money when the rains
come oh my God okay the chicken thighs
you guys feel moved
like I have a serious question do you
ser Ste them and crisp them and brown
them yeah okay you didn't put that in
the notes well I gave you my notes were
very eating like raw chick she like wait
I was supposed to cook them and you also
need to Stew the vegetables down a
little longer okay they look like maybe
they're just a little bit hard do you
have any other chicken thigh recipes
because ever since I made those I'm like
CH I'm a chicken thigh I'll give you the
easiest thing to make the easiest thing
to make that is so pack full of flavor
is adobo which is a Filipino classic
all you need is soy sauce vinegar garlic
pepper corn or you go to Whole Foods
they have it already seasoned for that's
how I do it thato yeah um and oh and bay
leaf it's it's very easy very simple
like people can add more things if they
want but add its most basic that is very
good to eat they also are you eating it
with rice on the side what on side r
with rice I will never I'm actually
having a Hawaii flashback to the
breakfast what breakfast we have
breakfast at that place oh yeah that's
right were you were looking at what I
was eating I'm so sick of the I'm
actually so mad right now what's going
what's coming up she I ordered what she
ordered I'm literally like I'm tearing
up I'm getting mad I was betrayed I
ordered what she ordered I go this is
what we're eating we did a
workout I go oh we get to eat this I
guess this is how Kila stays fit she
eats like [__] after she does a what was
it pancakes it was like biscuits and and
gravy and what was
it it was it was like a locom moco but
we had um Like Biscuits on the side and
stuff so I'm like oh my God this so we
can eat all this so I go I just go at it
on a bed of rice I'm like this is
incredible this many carbs like and you
can look like Kila I'm I get in the
moment I'm eating I finish it I'm
licking the plate I look over she's
eating one [__] bite push it side and
left she's leaving the
restaurant I can't uneat the food I was
like are you [__] kidding me I at the
I ate the protein down with me I'm sorry
if we didn't exercise together we're now
on the exact same caloric diet you need
to remember for the rest of the week she
was gone I literally was like you need
to remember the rule if we're in Hawaii
and a Hawkeye walks by kilo might go
missing I'm gone so fast that's how she
stays fit there's a lot of hot guys
there really are no I couldn't the
betray it was so [__] up no you know
what your mistake was you went biscuits
first you always go protein first
Kila it has wrong it doesn't have to do
with Hunger you didn't ask you're like K
what are you starting with
I she was gone and then there's an extra
plate left over her I'm not going to
just leave the food
there I couldn't believe it I remember
that breakfast she didn't say slow down
there was nothing you know what I
learned that day it's like even if
you're not the target like cuz you you
know I I was innocent at that meal but I
was still
scared I was so really scared
well it was the same trip as when you
tried to steal my weed I did not try to
steal your weed the guy gave me the weed
I wasn't even smoking weed at that time
she didn't smoke weed that's I was like
give get it the [__] out of your car now
it's but you were so SC I like saw you
from a car ahead you're
like I was so I like take it take it
you're wearing a puffer jacket by the
way she was like incognit in a puffer
jacket inai my allergies in Hawaii are
it's they're literally not like that
anywhere else I you yell you for your
allergies it was fun there is no I don't
have everyone got it on the trip I will
say everyone got it on the trip we all
caught straight we all everyone was like
had moments on that trip there was an un
there there was one unedited moment or
one edited moment where I went I always
knew you were a piece of [__] you're a
surprise they never made it on the show
but that was my favorite trash Tuesday
line
wait that is so funny you're a
surprise it's also so funny to look over
at me and say I always knew I knew you
but
you Howe GE like howy a c down Howe was
Carlos there who what what was Carlos
ever here can we make Carlos up I don't
even know Carlos is real segment of our
imagination we need another trip like
there's so and I welcome any I welcome
any of everything that happened leaving
ditching you guys in Hawaii is one of
the best I knew you were gonna be so
jealous I was I did wever talk about
when I left Hawaii yes okay because it's
the best thing I ever did I sorry I just
guess I don't feel like I got enough
credit for it but Irish could buying a
vacation and then thinking Esther was
going to be on the plane I was so
convinced you had the same idea I can't
believe I didn't but you know what
changing flights is like like so
complicated that I didn't even think of
it and also was the biggest power move
no that was one of the biggest storms
that hit I still think like we were like
it's now or never we were sliding to the
airport the guy driving was like get in
quick remember when we flew in to Kawaii
they the it took the pilot eight times
to land and we were in the air for
another hour he was like I got to try
that again guys we got to try that again
guys and that's like the third time I
was like oh this isn't good I Vegas or
Palm Springs would make sense for us I
was just in Vegas yeah and there was
this billboard that really kind of
stumped me and it was like you know how
they have all of those lawyers lawyers
always have like Billboards and stuff
and one of them said like injured while
looking for dead bodies in Lake me call
and then the number and I'm like that is
the strangest thing there are people
there's a group of people that have been
injured looking for dead bodies in Lake
me
like how does that make sense and who
are they getting to sue for that yeah
they must have the same lawyers as the
bloodbath girls like is that a hobby
that people have is just like
tracking oh my sister-in-law's sister is
like obsessed with she's on all these
like they try to solve murders Stu like
sleuths and
stuff it's crazy I that is kind of a
cool habit or a good hobby that's like a
helpful positive Hobby it's not positive
though your life goes L but you're
helping like cuz a lot of those cases
like they just don't have the resources
cuz nobody cares and they go cold but
even that um don't [__] with cats yeah
um with Luca magnat it was with the help
of the internet that he eventually got
found right that is crazy to
think I I couldn't watch it sothing
really is like you know that was a good
one you can watch it that was a really
good one really really great D and dear
Zachary are the best dear Zachary is too
[__] it's too enraging for me because
there was no win at the
end but there were so many
losses just loss after loss after loss
that was a [__] up one okay so I have
a topic um the
fly why does it like me sorry guys don't
don't be
jealous um okay so I have like a group
of friends and within it
basically there's been this issue that
has come up and I want to know what you
guys think because I see several sides
of it in a way basically I have a friend
who she has a boyfriend and they're
great they've been together like five
years they're a great couple they're
solid we all love this couple and one of
our mutual
friends she the the girlfriend in this
couple has shared with me that one of
our mutual friends consistently side
text
her boyfriend now none of these texts
are inappropriate none of them cross a
line you know to the naked eye
whatever but she's still like why are
you texting my boyfriend like no one
else te guess we're all friends but no
one else just texts my boyfriend like
it's just weird it just like there's
something coming up for her that makes
her uncomfortable and when she told me
this I'm like I actually completely
agree and if one of my friends was
tating my boyfriend I I would just feel
so weird even though I want to say
because I think this is an important
factor I know these people I really my
honest opinion is that there is nothing
Shady about it but I get why it's
bothersome what kind of texts are they
though I need some examples it'll just
be like remember this it's like very
random you know what it is it's like why
are you seeking male attention from the
guy that's my guy
yeah yeah also it's like throw her in
the group chat yeah you know so there's
no weirdness because this has happened
to my best friend too so my best friend
um went to Hawaii with me on vacation
but she has um she has a toddler and a
husband at home and one of my our really
good friends Texas the husband while
we're in Hawaii and she's like do you
need help with a baby I can come over
and help and the husband then tells my
best friend she's like oh hey so and so
texted me asking if I needed help with a
baby and my friend was like oh [__] no
why wouldn't she ask me yeah weird why
wouldn't she add me to that group text
and so even though it wasn't shady she
was like but she called her out
immediately she called and she was like
Hey dude like that's not appropriate
like that's my [__] husband if you
wanted to help we can talk about it as a
group but like throw me in there and how
did that person react um I think that
you know
she was like oh I just thought that you
needed the help you were out of town I
was trying to be like nice but my friend
was like thank you but also don't like
the way you went about it yeah it did
yeah it's weird cuz it's like yes on
paper there's nothing wrong with it but
there is something that deeply for me
make would make me uncomfortable if like
one of my friends was just like casually
texting or chatting or offering up help
like is's just something weird about it
like I would just I would never do that
I don't and again even if it was even if
I had something completely innocent to
share with Todd why why would I do that
I just don't like it it doesn't feel
right like maybe I'll say something to
you like you should show this to Todd
that yeah like even I had a friend who
um she was always wanting to throw me
like surprise things like that and she
would like text Todd and Todd would just
immediately be like this girl's crazy
she's trying to like do weird like
because he just knows I would never want
to be
surprised and it was always like the the
part of it that was annoying was she
always wanted to do it at like Whitney's
it's like there was always some sort of
surprise party where she'd be meeting my
celebrity friends she would somehow be
at my celebrity friend's house well
that's also a thing too where it's like
if someone knows that you're going to
say no wait and then what how about when
I'm trying to think of like we've had
weird things with with our groups of
friends too where we like introduce our
friends and then all of a sudden they
sidebar and try to hang out because our
some of our friends are yeah that's like
a thing pretty successful and then they
do like a sideb barring like almost like
we were just the intro yeah and then
you're like why are you guys on a hike
without yeah all of a sudden you're like
why how did I get out of this equation
they're like trying to like steal your
famous friends whatever no but but I
mean do you hear what I'm like like your
friend knew probably that you would say
no I'm not having you throw something at
wi's house so they go to like Todd is
like a nice guy so they're like Todd but
he is not that like Todd's nice but he's
not like people fall for he's quieter
but he will tell me everything at all
times always and that's in this couple
like the guy tells the girlfriend right
away and
how did they deal with
it I don't think they I think it just
makes my friend
uncomfortable and but there's nothing
because there's nothing wrong happening
there's like nothing there should just
always be a group chat I don't know why
there wouldn't be a group chat it's like
why would you not exactly like what it's
not that hard to throw it's and even
when I when I'm the opposite like when I
meet when my guy friends get girlfriends
I am so like interested in like
developing something with that you know
what I mean like I I try to not be too
like Side bar with the guy now they're
in a relationship it's like different so
this same girl that I was talking about
who texted my friends like husband um in
our friend group when one of our guy
friends brings over a new girl she likes
to Mark the guy in front of the new girl
so she'll sit on his lap she'll hug them
she'll she basically to show like hey he
was my friend first and look how
physically close we are and my my sister
and all of us all the other girls are
like what the [__] is she doing how rude
also like just gross Behavior what
causes that how are you like I know
we're all very different people I don't
maybe like what what in your right mind
would make you do that unless you like
have like an evil agenda about it like
you want to like piss someone off I just
think that's so wrong and I think there
is it's look it's awesome when like your
friends become friends with your partner
like that's a beautiful great thing
but there's still to me something sits
not right about like a side text even if
it's completely innocent I still don't
like it you to plan something for you it
makes me think it makes me think that
but even with that like Todd is like
when Todd was trying to figure out how
he wanted to propose to me and stuff he
would be like do you want me to talk to
Whitney do you want me like he would
like ask for like he never was like
doing a that's the only time it's
allowed right if they're planning
something for you whether it's a
birthday thing or whatever but not to
just spontaneously be like remember this
Fus but I will say that there's a girl
we might even be talking about the same
girl
who when I was dating a comic and we
would go to The Comedy Store she would
so obviously be trying to get this like
attention from him in front of me and we
would like basically laugh in her face
she'd be trying to like throw her [__]
around in front of like it was just so
weird it was really really really weird
yeah just like uh okay yeah I've had
that same thing too where like a guy was
dating like the the female friend has to
like why are you always touching his arm
in front of me like why why are you
always touching his arm in front of his
girlfriend what's the [__] point of
that I just I don't know I have really
strict rules about that like if I have a
male friend who's bringing in a new girl
the way even I talk to him is completely
different it's bro dude very standoffish
cold like also you kind of realize
sometimes if you have had a little bit
of an inappropriate relationship you go
like oh once there's like a witness and
someone that you go like oh wait maybe I
had been like flirting with this person
more than I needed to be or whatever or
like too comfortable or
something yeah I would never want her
like I recently met someone like Bobby
is dating right and um I was very like
this with him and I would rather she
feel like come in feeling like warm and
feeling like there's no threat to their
relation you know what I mean like I
wouldn't do that to another girl it must
then just be like an insecurity thing
right it's like are you just so insecure
that you just you can't help yourself
you just have to touch and show off this
person probably has never been in a
relationship with a guy where there's
just that like underlying respect where
you tell each other everything and oh
man you know because she would it would
it's like really how do you not know
yeah how do you not know that he's like
not pick you're not the picked you
haven't been picked yeah wait I have
some fan gossip you guys you ready for
this okay here we
go
okay okay fan
gossip so I'm in my first healthy
relationship ever and I'm so happy and
love him and for the first time I feel
like I see us getting married having
kids in the future my ex of 3 years and
I broke up like October of last year but
we would still text and see each other
sometimes he ghosted me beginning of
this year and now is randomly blowing up
my phone for over a month now he is
sending stuff like screenshots of me
saying that I'd always be there for him
and that hearing my voice would give him
life and it just pisses me off that he
waits until now to give me all the love
I ever wanted I went through months and
months of pain and heartbreak and
begging the universe to stop loving him
and I did so much healing and I was so
happy single and in my healing girl era
that's when my current boyfriend came
out of nowhere and we both weren't
looking for anything but we fell in love
my ex texting me has really made me feel
crazy because why does it make my heart
race and why does it bother me tale is
old this time oh Lord anxiously attached
it's more exciting no it's just the guys
know when you moved on and they want
they they just come out of the they come
back and they want to torture you and
they don't even like you and it's it's
not that it's not that you're special to
them it's just that they're bored and
they want to torture you and you got
addicted to like the excitement of like
not
being satisfied basically and once
you're in a healthy relationship it's
like it almost reads boring because
you're so used to this like adrenaline
rush and stuff roller coaster
ofs but that's um I think Esther's right
I think that he does not want you back
he does not like you and you should hang
on to that fact and but and you don't
have to always be there for anyone ever
even if you promised them to that is
correct crazy also that feeling of like
why does it excite you um is so normal
because it's something that you never
had and finally it's coming back around
and he's offering things that you prayed
and prayed for but I um he's not going
to give you those things I can that if
he really had changed and became a
better person he would actually just
like let you go and set you free and see
that you you've moved on like what
you're going through is so relatable I
feel like everyone I know has literally
gone through this scenario where they
like have the hardest time getting over
a guy they finally move on and the guy
just smells it in the air and he comes
back and there's nothing less healthy
than a man like screen grabbing
something you sent him like forever ago
and then out of context and then trying
to force you to
like
to keep your promise or whatever it's I
would block block and I could see how if
you feel that like heart racy excitement
you think it means like oh my God he's
the one but it's just like a slot
machine casino game it's not that it's
just a dopamine hit in the moment and
it's don't start talking [__] on slot
machine but that's exactly what it is
it's a very surface level feeling and
it's just the rush of things I don't
think you should um suppress that either
just you know feel the excitement but
don't do anything without excitement
because that's a dead end he was a dead
end before he's going to be a dead end
again if if you since October of last
year he hasn't done that much
changing it hasn't been that long
there's no way no you're on the right
path though yeah stay with this boy
block block block block block block
block block for yourself it's going to
feel good okay we have another one the
subject is I accidentally had sex with
my stalker okay where could this go I
matched with this guy on hinge and his
name was under which I assumed was a
nickname because nobody has named cut to
going out with him and we end up having
sex at my place he stayed night and left
the next morning everything was normal I
started thinking about how his name
couldn't be so I looked up his number on
zel smart and his name came up as Andrew
I Google Andrew and the Instagram of the
guy who's been harassing me in my DMs
for 3 years is the first thing that pops
up I stopped looking at his profile
years ago and he never posted pictures
of himself when he first started
harassing me but when I went to his
profile he had recently posted a picture
of himself and there was my hinge date
his DMS have been Relentless over the
last 3 years he didn't he he sent me 20
messages at a time and then we'll unsend
to make it look like nothing is there he
didn't mention that he knew who I was
the entire date what do I do do I move
call the cops block him and I'm scared
from her life and feel so deceived H
what do I do that is crazy so she
actually had sex with
him oh my God so this guy's like been
obsessed with
you uh get a ring camera
today Honestly though I know this is
like sad in its own way but I in but
also a relief I feel like he got what he
wanted and maybe he can move on
now I mean
like or it could get wor but I'm sorry
that is some violating if you are
sending a a
stranger text messages for three [__]
years you hinged wait the text and the
unsending text are is that happening
after they up no I think that was
happening for the last 3 years I
honestly have to move sorry that is
scary yes they can't know no I think
Annie's right you have to move you have
to move you have to move this person is
unhinged for three years Esther that
would be like me going into my DMs right
now and looking at all the guys who call
me you gold digging [__] blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah for years and years
and years and then finding out like
tomorrow that I actually like [__] him
and they know
scary that's really scary and now they
know who I am where I live what my dogs
look like what my towels look like what
my bed looks like
window like I say move move I would also
contact the police would be my first
thing and I would explain what what's
going on um they're not going to do [__]
the cops aren't going to I know but
sometimes they can have good
advice like and
they and you do want to keep a record
and just keep an eye on it especially if
you have any screenshots of the
harassment um and I would confront him
or maybe not just block maybe just block
that's tricky yeah they always say don't
block your stalkers but I'm like block
I'd want to confront and be like what
the [__] but then I'd also be really
scared to do that but then if you do um
record it just in case you have that
conversation with him um but have a like
already be moved out to the new place
before here's what I think here's what I
think this is like like a weird
opportunity for you to get a new place
and start a new life and it's going to
be weird and but you got to move I would
move the hell out of that place I know
but sometimes like you're not in a
financial position to move like it's you
have but but you can figure it out you
can stay with someone do something until
you can figure it out you have to it's
not like someone it's not this guy
didn't just text her for you know two
days for three years he did this did he
do it for three straight
years yeah
but I don't know this is it's definitely
scary and so violating and I feel
terrible
this for doing it to KLA this is a
horror story for sure and please keep us
posted and let us know like if you have
other questions guys if we can keep you
safe that's so yeah next time like it
you know dissect the name a little bit
like do I really want to have sex with a
guy
named maybe
skip um how do you guys feel about sex
schedules and planning sex
dates not even if you have kids but just
because let's suppose like you both have
busy schedules and you're like okay we
haven't been intimate in x amount of
time maybe we should PL go you know do
this start it you got to [__] start it
back up sometimes you really do I think
you're right I think it's fine you just
don't want to have it be the whole your
whole life yeah that but every once in a
while you got to like you guys get busy
or whatever you got to be like oh [__]
we have to bang I like it in the sense
of it's like okay I know like this day
I'm going to be eating this meal and I'm
not going to feel it and like so or like
be eating
this or like okay I'm G to be working
all day maybe that's so then I'll be
like okay like somay I only have one
thing in the day and like I'm going to
have something light or whatever like
that that I'll in my head I'll be like
that's a good day for that to happen
here's the thing it's like when you're
doing a comedy set right like you want
to have like an idea of what it's going
to be an outline but there's still room
to do crowd work you know yeah like you
yeah you plan your week it's like a meal
plan you know you you put pin it in
around the meals that it makes sense I I
can see how it can be a good thing
because now you have um
you're like you know it takes sometimes
like a little bit more time for our
engines as women to be revved up but if
I have a date in mind where it's like
okay 7 p.m. on a Thursday then I can
sort of get in the mood well before and
I can get my G my my my mind right um so
that could be advantageous like that day
I'll put on like a different pair of
underwear that I know are going to make
me feel a certain type of way cuz you
know he's not going to do all that put
on the under going to do the make the
effort to actually like seduce you at
800 in the morning to get to the 700
p.m. sex so it's like sometimes you do
have to do that for yourself yeah I
think that I think this is that's like
the way is the like loose outline yeah
cuz yeah then you don't like because you
could just if you did schedule it would
you schedule it in the morning afternoon
never morning never anything other than
morning got to be spontaneous you can't
do morning on afternoon quite honestly
like I think that biologically this is
where God if that's what you believe in
this is where he [__] up um I think
Morningwood makes no sense because I
can't think of a time I've ever just
been that sleepy or that horny like
sleepy and horny are not two things I
ever feel so it's like let me [__]
sleep get that thing off of my ass right
now like do not touch me I need a couple
more hours I've never felt horny like
that in the morning have you never no I
just in the morning I'm just like just
trying to be happy so hard I just like
wake up
[Laughter]
like I'm like yeah it's early afternoon
late afternoon that's it before I've
been in relationships ear we morning
bang a lot but that was just a guy that
made me [__] him all day anyway like a
[__] sex lab for years yeah you got
bullied into it yeah I mean yeah I was
like I'm gonna I don't want to get
yelled at it because I'll [__]
him sometimes it's fun though in the
beginning in the beginning of a
relationship in the beginning sure I'll
do it anytime they want to it's fun but
if we're like we're a couple of years in
like please like don't even breathe in
my direction in the morning I just want
to sleep I definitely have like a
dessert mentality about it where it's
like it's like the last thing of the day
like you know after dinner no way I'm
out no pre- dinner pre- dinner and then
you you you reward yourself with a
really good meal cuz you're so hungry
you worked up an apple no she likes to
[__] when she's full yeah I don't mind a
full stomach she's got a good excuse to
lay there no don't you just after dinner
don't you just want to just sit and fart
for a couple
hours you can like take your time those
AR mutually
exclusive I think we're good po Todd oh
my God poor Todd why I just don't even
like try to be sexy anymore I mean I'm
just like so he's just getting farted on
most of the
day
it's life you guys but you guys have a
very very strong special
love you're the parents to 14 children
so many so many
reptiles Esther you want to wrap it up
you guys thank you so much for another
wild ride together um we love you we
have new merch check it out we're all
cute in it finally and we will see you
next week with a brand new episode love
you
[Music]
guys